what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch today from new rock
stars the moon night episode 1 easter
eggs and breakdown we haven't seen a
reaction that's up on the channel of
course new rockstars the best in the biz
and before we proceed any further a
couple things i got to mention first
thing is might hear some more background
noise than usual ac currently not
working in our place and we wanted to
crack the window open but unfortunately
they're doing a lot of construction
outside secondly
i already ordered a new rock stars moon
knight shirt so ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha
ha ha ha
to all of you
but especially you
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of marvel's
moon night episode 1 as we meet our hero
grappling with dissociative identity
disorder and one of those identities
possessed by an egyptian moon deity
which gives us all a new cover story for
when we obliterate our friends bathrooms
i swear it was con sugar [ __ ] in the tub
as we always here at new rockstars we're
gonna break this down in depth because
unlike other mcu titles moon knight is
less about the marvel easter eggs than
it is truly impressive cinematic details
that make this series a fascinating
mystery and character exploration the
episode opens not with the hero but with
the villain arthur harrow tattooed on
his armor scales head in the mouths of
crocodiles those croc heads also on the
head of a staff the egyptian deity he
serves emmett a funeral figure
associated with judgment seen with the
head of a crocodile front legs of a lion
in hindquarters of a hippopotamus the
egyptians believe that when you die the
god of the dead anubis weighs your heart
on scales against the weight of a
feather and if it weighs more you are
fed to emmet amit was not worshipped as
a god per se but feared by egyptians as
the devourer of the dead dooming them if
they didn't adhere to the principle of
ma'at which referred to a way of life
that pursued truth and balance and
justice philosophically there's actually
a lot in common here with thanos another
mcu villain with a religious zeal to
cull all of life by half but whereas
thanos saw fairness in randomness harrow
and his disciples believe that one soul
should be judged on its merits past
present and future at least you can
imagine in a post-thanos society once
bait being determined by a bit more
order is the cult mentality kool-aid
flavor more folks would like the taste
first off we gotta see abbott that would
be amazing oh yeah if we could get that
character into the actual series i would
absolutely love that hopefully it's not
a cgi mess
but it would be cool to actually bring
that to life secondly i mean yeah that's
part of why i think this god that they
worship is such a fascinating one
because it creates such a moral
complexity like can you really judge
someone and determine whether their soul
is worthy of still existing on this
earth based on the
future minority reports and as the
future
like set in stone is it a
estimation how does this account for the
multiverse and the various branches that
can be caused by different decision
making is it just on this timeline that
your soul is unworthy yeah it's true how
does this factor to the turtles the tva
everything else in his ritual he
shatters a glass and then puts the
broken pieces in his sandals walking on
them with bare feet now walking on john
every day of practice but harrow hides
this inside his shoes spending the whole
day enduring great pain but telling no
one this tells us that he's not doing
this for show he is a true believer and
the music we hear is bob dylan's every
grain of sand one of dylan's 80s
spiritual tracks recorded after he found
jesus became born again christian kind
of like how arthur harrow sees himself
as a reborn evangelist every great
observer refers to how dylan saw the
master's hand in every tiny particle of
nature and for hero in every person he
sees emmett's judgment that could be
another reason he walks on this broken
glass with every step he pulverizes this
glass back into grains of sand yes
that's what glasses it's sand when it's
super heated the marble studios title
card oh that's clever that's really
clever the eternals can be seen on the
inside hey now
by the way finally back where peter
parker was in the no way home title card
because peter can only appear in
live-action titles that sony proves up
and by approves of i mean get some money
to pay for their poopy vampire booties
hey bob dylan to anglebert humberdinks a
man without love which is about a man
who wakes up every day realizing he's
alone the first one actually juxtaposes
stephen's inability to remember his past
love layla and the third line reflects
how moonlight now shows him the way via
his new soulmate one that he is not yet
aware of khanshu the egyptian moon deity
and we made steven grant now in the
comics steven grant is actually the
second identity of mark spector mark is
really the main figure the badass
mercenary that we start with and steven
is a new identity he adopts that of an
elite billionaire but i assume this
series changed steve into this awkward
museum employee to avoid the batman
bruce wayne comparisons because when
moon knight first came out in the marvel
comics a lot of people considered him
marvel's batman well it's a fascinating
choice that they actually made with this
because i've only read one series of of
moon nightmare act like i've read a
bunch of one that was illustrated by
greg smallwood back in i think 2016 and
that one in the backstory of mark
specter the identities formed at such a
young age and he like kind of grew up
with
you know both jake lockley which is one
of the personalities and stephen grant
as well where in this show it's like
he's meeting them for the first time so
i'm wondering like what direction this
show will actually go down i'm like oh
they have always been there and he like
suppressed them forgot who they are is
mark the dominant personality still
there's a lot to really unpack her and i
like how they really flipped it on its
head now behind steven's bed as he
awakes are a number of texts on world
history and architecture ancient egypt
etc these books hovering over his head
as he sleeps reflects how his dreams or
what he thinks are his dreams take him
back to that world now in the foreground
you can see his rubik's cube completed
which is interesting because not trying
to stay awake steven intentionally
fiddles with it and tosses it never
finishing it suggesting that when the
mark identity takes over he might go
ahead and solve the rubik's cube that's
the first thing mark does now you gotta
get this done otherwise i'm gonna be
able to focus on my conscious work
before i go to the alps wait wait caught
you
let me just solve this rubik's cube
really fast i'll be there then i'll go
we see how he strapped his leg the bed
and surrounded himself with sand all as
a kind of sleepwalking security measure
but his first real step forward of the
day is his bare foot on sand which the
camera lingers on showing he is more
connected to the sands of egypt than
harrow whose first step
dude
great dude you're blowing my mind
because i did not actually know that's
where glasses did you know that i know
that i i didn't actively be like oh he's
grinding it down into the sand but yeah
yeah but i think that's cool especially
with the show that you're so much of
reflections and mirroring to then mirror
that with our main character and the
antagonist as well so early on upon the
introduction my mind actually never
caught up that i didn't know that the
last episode marx is going to be there
filling his shoes with sand then
his goldfish gus is only one working fin
like nemo in comparison the pet store
owner later invokes but with one working
fin this poor guy is literally swimming
in circles just like stephen is and you
can see at the bottom of the fish tank
is lined with a pyramid king tut's head
an egyptian obelisk and a sunken boat he
talks to his mother on the phone
probably talking to no one hello mom
it's me
just checking in
um i got your postcard putting it up on
gus's tank now now assuming steven's
mother doesn't really exist is he
sending himself these postcards is mark
sending them to stephen to help keep him
in that dormant routine later on does he
have a mother personality a rack of
postcards so perhaps this is where he's
getting the postcards that he's mailing
to himself he says goodbye to his mom oh
man that's interesting
i'll try again tomorrow later later
crocodiles are different from alligators
we talked about this in loki but it will
be later that he faces this taxonomic
order of reptiles but also this all
poses the question if stephen grant is
just another identity of mark spector
who does steven think he is talking on
the phone to is he just leaving
voicemails with a random number is there
a voice in box that mark specter set up
to help stephen along with this charade
it's just interesting how all of
steven's closest relationships are
people who cannot talk back to him like
the street reporter now behind that bus
island
atlantis home of namor or maybe just
another building called atlantis yeah
actually
definitely exteriors and budapest so
later budapest should be london's
national museum of art the architecture
is actually that of budapest's museum of
fine arts they use vfx to swap out the
hungarian for english and this museum is
first shown
of a puddle that stephen steps through
reflections and mirrored surfaces are a
recurring motif in this series all the
way around showing how steven comes
steven catches a girl stuffing her gum
in a mini pyramid of giza it's not like
there's anything in there
yeah
maybe not
but
in there
something wicked a lie foreshadowing in
two ways of course the wicked jackal
that stephen will flee in this museum
later but also trailer footage suggests
that steven or mark will explore the
great pyramids of giza and they might
find something inside of them also
something
wicked
wicked this way comes in the play the
witches are foreseen a monster i love it
which here it goes
for steven the hero of this story the
monster is currently inside of him he
explains the issues from burial
and the girl responds with and did it
suck for you getting rejected from the
field of reads what if that makes sense
because i'm not dead am i stevie
yeah am i that oscar isaac sneaks in
showing how this girl triggered his
recent lapses with reality even now he
doesn't know if he's alive or dead also
weird question for that girl to ask i
don't trust that kid later
you know like the super group of
egyptian gods you know you've got horus
there's
osiris
a major blunder because they've got
seven gods here and the inaudible now he
is correct that the idiot of egyptian
mythology has nine members the sun god
atom his children shu and tefnet their
children geb and nuts remember all this
but this poster also lists hathor the
sky goddess who is not usually listed
among the indiana despite being a very
important deity who we should note mates
with konshu the moon
yeah
hell it mirrored yeah
[Music]
mirroring and every abraham getting it
on an egyptian
and use a foreign nepotism to get around
the antihed there you know hey you're
with me you're a god now you're one of
the big gods now let's do it let's do it
let's do it
egyptian god's big
that's why can't you so upset people
he's got blue boxes
blue moon balls i'll take it out on
everyone else until i get my woman back
based on promo material we will likely
see the nine members of the annie had in
their human avatars later this season
stephen chats with this gold painted
street performer listed in the credits
as crawley now in the comics bertrand oh
[ __ ] in new york who serves as an
informant to moon knight he walks around
posing as a british aristocrat we get
another awesome no no
as steven says goodbye to crawley what
we initially think is right side up is
actually upside down when a leaf drops
on the puddle on the top half of the
frame that's pretty cool and that could
just be the way kind of like how hawkeye
did that with um
yeah where it's like let's just give him
that character name but he's not
actually going to be a portrayal of that
but it seems very intentionally placed
that it would be crawly and it seems
like he would be in a perfect position
to fill that role in this new statue
form exactly we passed the scene and i
want to point this out with the girl but
he doesn't remember setting up a date
with her yeah i'm going to give credit
heavy spoilers paul he
talked to me about this literally just a
theory but the theory was like dude
that's mind-blowing what he was telling
me was mark spector as established in
the show is married he has a wife layla
so why would he be going on a date with
this girl why would he ask her out and
wouldn't she pick up on the fact that
mark spector has an american accent so
that other personality might have
actually been mark's other personality
jake locklear
yeah what did it would do a lot more
sense yeah and steven tries to stay
awake in his textbook there's a mention
of the great rift god's turn away from
man which feels like it's setting up
this show's mythology with konshu and
the nine indiana members relationship to
mankind we're basically adding a new
layer to the mcu plan of implying all
gods of human society from the history
we know are interwoven with marvel
mythology as we saw with the asgardian's
connections with norse mythology and the
eternal's connections with all other
forms of mythology we have yet to see
how the christian religion ties into all
of that but my friends methisto is
coming
youngest to oldest it does seem a bit
out of order it's just a bit odd to list
osiris first whatever order you would go
in but remember all of this is through
the eyes of stephen who's certainly
knowledgeable about egyptian mythology
but he does have an unstable mind he is
an unreliable narrator a point of view
character through whom we are not seeing
objective reality necessarily so who
knows how much of this presented reality
is actually real and how much of it is
gonna be revealed as a fantasy at some
point he tosses up his rubik's cube and
he suddenly finds himself face down jaw
dislocated in the hills beside an alpine
village this is actually shot in
slovenia so apparently when stephen fell
asleep mark spector took over went to
the alps to steal the scarab from this
castle then left out the window and
steven woke up on the ground a voice
speaks to him go back to sleep worm yes
this is f murray abraham as konshu
interesting that he calls steven the
worm as is steven is the invasive
critter that does not belong inside the
mine konshu of course the egyptian deity
possessed mark spector choosing him as
his avatar giving mark supernatural
powers but he has less control over
mark's steven identity in his pocket he
finds a golden scarab with the egyptian
hieroglyphics you can actually see a
closer look at these in the closing
credits of the episode we did our best
to translate these but they do contain a
mix of known alphabeticals and then
other unknown ones the right and the
left halves of the scarab are mirrored
so if you look at the dividing line in
the middle and go to the column to the
right of that at the top of that that is
a read which translates to either an e
or an i beside a seated figure beneath
that there's a scarab shape then the
open mouth that's an r then another eye
beside a different seated figure than a
pair of figures the column to the right
of that is topped with the quail chick
that represents the u or the w followed
by another eye beneath that the vulture
that's an a and then a figure i don't
recognize that looks like either a boat
maybe an oil lamp and then the horned
viper that represents f and then another
figure it'll recognize i'm going to keep
working on these folks but uh
bunch of questions
for effort indiana jones fight club and
already you're seeing the parallels
there of course especially indiana joe's
last crusade which had a whole set piece
in a germanic castle but by sticking
is something that we've seen actually in
christopher nolan's memento which is
also told in a non-linear narrative
structure that reflected the mind the
protagonist who suffered from short-term
memory loss it resulted in him finding
himself in intense moments with no
knowledge of how he got there similarly
the fx series legion which actually
follows the marvel mutant of david
holler also explores the intersection of
superpowers with mental health struggles
and leaves the viewer never quite sure
of what is real or not interesting how
just a little indicator that these men
in their matching clothes are likely not
native to this alpine town but rather
like many cults in the real world move
to these places that just kind of like
take the town over with their
interesting vegetation outfits steven
pulls a harrison ford fugitive maneuver
by joining the procession with some
headgear to blend in in this case it's
his white hoodie white being the color
of moon knight's wardrobe arthur harrow
parts the crowd showing his long blown
out hair now harrow in the comics is
really a one-off villain from one issue
in 1985 a guy with a half-paralyzed face
carrying out some nazi experiments in
mexico really i think this guy's gonna
have a deeper identity that gets
revealed later in the series his
character's already much deeper
absolutely
what episode
yeah later we'll have a deeper identity
that later has way past who we are way
past later what would be happening for
more than one episode he's already way
off beyond before they had him in the
comics ethan hawk said his version of
the character is based on david koresh
leader of the christian cult the branch
davidians in waco texas one follower
submits himself for judgment i judge you
in amit's name with but a fraction of
her power the tattoo scales sync with
the swinging of the staff which turned
green to signal a balanced soul
meanwhile the old woman the tattoo turns
red with one scale having a larger pile
weighing it down i've been good my
entire life i believe you but the scales
see everything perhaps it's something
that lies ahead and so he drains her
life force leaving her skin gray so anna
judges her by the sins she will commit
in the future and unless this is all
[ __ ] and let's be honest it might be
this would be another example of destiny
existing in the mcu something described
in various ways by the ancient one and
he who remains in loki like the tva
pruning young sylvie this woman is being
punished for future violations both of
these systems of justice cruelly denying
the possibility of a multiverse where
people can make infinitely different
choices
i'm still on the train of what the hell
is this old woman gonna do in the future
she's gonna massacre some people
tomorrow she seems so old how bad can it
be of what she actually was gonna do
what character change could she enact in
herself to be that bad yeah konshu
refuses to let steven hand over the
scarab kudos to oscar isaac for his
physical work here the way he can
divorce his head his facial expressions
from the rest of his body and then when
he marches away from harrow he takes
these big dramatic steps similar to the
big strides the towering concho himself
would take as they pry the scarab from
him stephen flickers in and out of
consciousness coming too with blood on
his face and fist just that amount of
blood on the scarab in his palm it's
some of the gruesomeness we've ever seen
the mcu get as it implies absolutely had
to rip off a few fingers to get that
scarab out of their hands he flees in a
cupcake delivery van so violent implied
crying out but steven wishes to be woken
up from this nightmare the fact that
this is playing on the radio maybe just
a bit of an ironic joke or just like an
interesting coincidence that one might
see in a dream steven grant wakes up for
this thinking it's a dream but as we
find out later it's not a dream so why
did such an ironic song play during it
then i just love all this director's
choice what seems real and what seems
fantasy as he struggles against his
pursuers he flashes forward again and
now find the gun in his hand the
windshield blown out that gunshot
shattered the side window and one of
those pursuing cars flipping i love how
this whole scene plays out like a
classic card chase with one person
steering one person shooting but with
one man doing everything and only seen
half of it think how terrifying that
would be a logging truck overturns and
he swerves around it two more trucks
wedge around him and then mark takes
over again
[Music]
yeah i like how on the transition out of
it you hear the gunshot as if the
gunshot is what woke steven up the
gunshot that probably shot the driver of
that sedan but before the logs crush
them steven wakes up he thinks back home
presumably mark was able to get out of
that somehow made his way back to the uk
back into the apartment and back into
bed and shopper behind proves this
showing stephen with reflections on
either side of him proving his truly
split identity yet his leg harness the
sand ring the door tape all seemingly
undisturbed but think about it if it was
another identity taking over not him
sleepwalking mark would have been fully
capable of avoiding the sand replacing
the tape himself it's a huge pile of
crumbled tape in that trash can i highly
doubt steven counted all the watts you
know i just want to say too that there's
been some people who have been kind of
upset by that action sequence for not
seeing the action
and i'm like well we'll get the action
you know we will yeah we will get it the
whole point is to thrust you into the
perspective of what steven grant is
going through i've seen a lot of people
feel like they've
cheated no it's gonna be like night and
day where he blacks out every time
there's an action scene that would be
great all
success deal with it off screen would
save a lot of money to save a lot of
time multiple personalities and we're
only going to see it only from stevens
the entire time yeah let's never see the
actions
gus now has a second fully functioning
finn as indicated by the pet store clerk
mark during that last period must have
replaced the goldfish kind of like
parents who replace kids goldfish when
the fish die and they hope the kids
don't notice stephen realizes he misses
date at the steak restaurant because
it's sunday not friday i'll have a state
please
sure
what cut would you like i i'll have the
best bit of the uh
mistake that's the bit that i want
center cuts fill it um how do you like
that good yeah very good very good yeah
another
well done okay
[Music]
delicious
oof for anyone who eats steak this is
painful to watch you never cook a family
to
i'd rather eat poodle [ __ ] but obviously
stephen is a vegan and mark was the meat
eater who picked this steakhouse to
begin with he finds some scratches on
his apartment floor for where the team
is
to access the hidden crawl space and on
the cell phone that he finds all the
calls are to layla except for duchamp
christina
an ex-french foreign legion officer who
is a partner to mark specter in the
comics mark's voice speaks to him and he
sees the reflection of bathroom mirror
shaking his head when steven hadn't done
so he flees the elevator which stops
mysteriously on an empty third floor and
then again on the second where konshu
lurches toward him from the end of the
hall terrifying horror imagery here as
in the comics ganshi has a big skull and
a crescent moon staff and his limbs are
wrapped in linen like a mummy though i
like how his tail wrappings seem to
float as if detached from gravity just
amazing character design here kanchu
grabbing the lift door turns it into an
elderly woman but even that doesn't make
total sense think about it because if
she was at the other end of the hall she
would be nowhere near the summoning
button and despite this elevator
previously headed down from the second
floor it's now back up on the fifth
floor where his elderly neighbor is
visiting her friend claire and we saw
steven repeatedly hit the button for the
ground floor it should not have gone
back up to the fifth now sure this may
just be the building's electrical
problems that stephen alluded to or
maybe khan shoes screwing with him but
really i think another example of how
basic things in steven's reality are not
abiding by normal logic steven turns
around and see konju right behind him i
love this close up because you can see
all the texturing and indentations on
conscious skull like the little hairs
walking out for the back of it but now
when we whip panda practical reaction
he's back on the bus meaning from the
fifth floor to now mark must have been
in control we see konshu standing on the
street but he disappears when the
lamppost crosses frame on his bus steven
realizes as he hops up harrow was on
that bus so either mark was pursuing or
more likely being pursued by arthur
herrera before steven regained control
harrow and his followers corner stephen
at the museum had almost been free
she would have prevented hitler in the
destruction erupt
nero the armenian genocide pol pot never
talks about the snap worst crimes
against humanity harrow invokes the baby
hitler thought experiment what if hitler
could have been prevented from becoming
the mass murdering dictator something
deadpool 2 addresses head on harrow goes
on to say but she was betrayed was she
by indolent fellow gods oh
by even her own avatar avatars
blue people love that film about avatar
you mean that i mean anime yeah steven
references both teams cameron's avatar
and avatar the last airbender but also
setting up the mystery of who emmett's
original avatar was and why they
betrayed him perhaps influences from the
eternals or maybe pharaoh rama tut aka
kang the conqueror who also judges
people by
than mark does and the destiny of this
total individual is really a complete
variable depending on whoever is taking
control now would that mean that anyone
with dissociative identity disorder that
harrow assessed would get the same
results maybe but i really think stephen
and mark's condition is amplified by
conscious possession making him uniquely
impossible to judge that night as the
museum closes the crescent moon glimmers
overhead we're telling this as the night
moon night will finally rise steven
passes his reflections and the two
others remain in the glass mark turning
back to see what is stalking stephen in
this case the jackal that moves in the
foreground a jackal released by arthur
harrow to recover the scarab in another
shot steven is perfectly framed behind a
half-broken bust just a really cool way
of showing how he is sharing his mind
with one of these ancient figures the
jackal appears again behind fascinating
fascinating
super creepy stephen flees into the
largest and nicest public museum
bathroom i've ever seen yes seriously
i can't have you fighting me this time
you need to give me control you
understand what control of what you're
talking about
that thing's about to break through the
door i love how for all of this we stay
in one take transitioning through whip
pants but staying in stephen's point of
view at first the mark reflection turns
to face him while all the other infinite
steven reflections match steven's
movement but after stephen turns to look
at the door and then back to mark now
only the mark reflections oh oh [ __ ]
even in identities in this mind but mark
has the full attention right now i love
that then the music cuts out as he says
that's so cool
you're not gonna die
let me save us and so steven finally
looks directly at mark into his eyes and
the transformation begins though notice
while the mummy wrappings envelop our
mark steven in the mirror reflections on
the side nothing is happening again from
the standpoint of objective reality it's
hard to really know how much of this is
truly real flickering on the bathroom
walls are glowing weird then we cut to
outside the bathroom initially hearing
the scuffle but then sink crashes
against the wall and the jackal tries to
flee but moonlight drags him back in
water pouring down from the broken sinks
giving us another mirrored surface to
reflect this character from below he
turns to us glowing white eyes from
behind the mummy wrappings in a hood
with a crescent moon sigil and a beaked
tip of that hood evoking the skull of
conscious suspended in his chest in
those mummy wrappings is this crescent
moon weapon our final image of the
episode leaves us with moon knight's
eyes glowing white like the moon the
color white is important to moon knight
described amazingly in charlie houston's
2006 comics i don't wear white to hide
myself i wear it so they'll see me
coming so they'll know who it is because
when they see white it doesn't matter
how good a target i am their hands shake
so bad they couldn't hit the moon
and it ends with the jackal being afraid
of its prey taking on the glowing
terrifying eyes of the hunter again
check out our awesome night yeah over at
new rockstars
you can follow me on instagram you'll
never know is that the one you've got
rockstars and subscribe to rockstar some
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye great job
two things i wonder like how far into
the whole fight club thing they'll go to
the point of damn was a lot of what we
saw just in his mind how crazy would
that be
and secondly
um
you'll never know which shirt it is that
i bought
i'm gonna wear it on camera dang it all
right guys well thank you so much for
being here it's been a
hell of a journey
and we'll catch you for the next moon
night episode thank you rockstars
[Music]